وصلنا قبل قليل المباراه بعد اقل من ثلاث
ساعات من الان هي تتحدث كثيرا صدقني من
قبل ما نحكي باللايف نوستوب نعم الكثير من
من الحافلات من من مشجعين المنتخب
الكرواتي وصلوا قبل قليل قبل مشجعين
المنتخب المغربي عبر هذه النشره انادي
المنتخب او مشجعين المنتخب المغربي ان
ياتوا الى هنا فقط سبقوكم الكروات الى هذه
المنطقه الى استاد خليفه
ههه لحظه
حسناوات على ذمتي طبعا
دلوقتي ويقولون نحن سنكون دائما معك يا
كرواتيا بجميع الاحوال حتى نشاهد النهايه
لهذا المباراه
رائعه بصراحه تسبق هذه المباراه ليف يعني
من جانب المنتخب الكرواتي واللي يمكن قدم
اداء اكثر من رائع في هذه البطوله خرج على
يد الارجنتين اليوم يلعبون تحديدا المركز
الثالث والرابع اسال ايضا كذلك لا يفعل
اجواء ما قبل المباراه النهائيه لديك في
همم الدوحه التي تستضيف هذه النسخه
الماليه كيف تبدو حماس الجماهير تطلعات
الامال كيف رصدتها
نايف انا لابس لفحه واذا شايف كثير هوا في
كثير ريح اليوم ناقل ان تكون الرياح
جنوبيه للمنتخب المغربي حتى تساعد على ان
تصل الكره الى الهدف او المرمى الكرواتي
لانه يعني اليوم يوم عاصف هنا في الدوحه
والكثير من الذين حضروا حضروا يرتدون طبعا
الاعلام اكيد يحملون الرايات رايات بلادها
ان كانت في المغرب
كثير من الوقت ان اشكرك جزيلا شكرا على
هذه الصوره التي نقلتها لنا من امام استاذ
خليفه الدولي بالدوحه شكرا لك